it's a wednesday p-f-t-o-t haven't done
this in a while haven't done it solo in
a while usually sims is around he's on
vacation he really needed a vacation he
was under a lot of stress it was a rough
week for him at the super bowl i'm just
being sarcastic it's normal to take
vacations i'm the one who's abnormal i
refuse to take time off i refuse to take
days off except when we are off the air
as we will be for the tour de france
tour de france
and the olympics later this year other
than that i'll be here every day with
pft live and from time to time with pft
ot some things we didn't get to today we
had big cat in the building on a
wednesday kind of different usually he's
here on friday one thing we didn't get
to emmanuel sanders due to be a free
agent when last we saw emmanuel sanders
he was wide open heading into the end
zone down 24-20 in super bowl 54. jimmy
garoppolo threw the ball over his head
sanders didn't appreciate the questions
about the play after the game and he
also doesn't appreciate questions based
upon his age as he approaches free
agency unrestricted style for the second
time in his career he wrote on twitter
it's crazy how people keep talking about
my age but i'm still flying past 23 year
olds and only had two drops the entire
year keep bringing up my age to make
yourself feel good but go look at the
film i'm still playing at a high level
and will continue to play at a high
level as long as i want
because my heart is immeasurable and my
work ethic is second to none look i
don't know if he's going to stay with
the 49ers if he doesn't they gave up a
lot to get him third round pick for a
half season rental
for a team that really wasn't throwing
the ball much in the playoff run can
they keep him i think they'd like to
i could see the patriots being in play
for emmanuel sanders that was a guy that
they were thinking about trying to trade
for before they traded for muhammad sunu
so we'll see what happens with sanders
but he clearly has self-confidence in
himself as sims would say and we'll see
if he can keep getting it done as he
gets farther and farther onto the wrong
side of the age of 30.
brandon cooks one of the best receivers
in the nfl is vouching for his
quarterback jared goff
cook says that goff absolutely is the
guy
i mean you talk about a guy that we had
so many different position changes along
the offensive line last year and for any
quarterback that is so tough
to still be able to stand in there and
take the licks it goes to show you that
this guy is willing to do whatever it
takes
to win for his team and at that young in
age when you have that mindset special
things happen look the the obvious
response is
it's smart for a receiver to keep his
lips on the buttocks of his quarterback
but yeah look i i'm critical of jared
goff from time to time just because
i'm looking for the next
wave of guys who are the guy and i don't
think jared goff frankly at this point
is the guy and yes i'm still
very cognizant of the play twice in
super bowl 53 when brandon cooks was
wide open first time goff didn't see him
second time saw him too late second time
championship throw he didn't make it i'm
skeptical i was skeptical of the
performance this year especially without
the punch in the running game
that todd gurley brings but that said
goff is capable of making some special
throws i think the thing
as we see more and more
mobile quarterbacks who can throw really
well it's going to make it more glaring
when there are
quarterbacks who can throw it really
well but who aren't
mobile because once that wall starts to
close in we see it with kirk cousins i
think we see it with jared goff as well
although he's got he's got some mobility
but no i'm talking about the guys who
can move the guys who can throw on the
run they got even aaron rodgers at age
36 he's in that group russell wilson
patrick mahomes kyler murray guys who
can move and throw with accuracy
precision velocity and distance those
are the guys who are going to take over
the nfl the guys who set up in the
pocket and can make the big throws
that's fine
the problem is when it all starts to
fall apart what are you going to do and
i think jared goff falls into that
category and what are the rams going to
do with todd gurley not being the guy
that he was that helped fuel what the
rams were in 2017 and 2018 no playoffs
this year for the rams what happens in
2020 with the seahawks the 49ers and
maybe an improving cardinals team
putting pressure on them jared goffman
very well be the guy
either way he's going to have a chance
to prove it one way or the other in 2020
because they'll need him to play at a
high level or they won't be back in the
postseason and that'll make it two
straight years of no playoffs the
vikings are in the playoffs every other
year under mike zimmer
and so
based upon the formula this year would
be a year that they missed the playoffs
and zimmer's entering the founding year
of his contract he expects to get an
extension he hasn't gotten one yet
regardless of whether or not the vikings
keep him around and look he's done
enough that i think he should stay
but you could make the argument you want
to see what happens in 2020 one thing
that will happen bringing in
a 3-4 defensive specialist in the form
of dom capers mike zimmer 4-3 dom capers
3-4 why is he doing this mike zimmer
told reporters on tuesday that he needs
some fresh ideas they've been running
the same defense since zimmer arrived as
the head coach back in 2014
they want to see some other ways of
doing things and i think this is smart
you know one of the reasons the vikings
i think reach a a plateau that they
can't punch through
some of the things they do defensively
are a little predictable it's a system
and you can find
deficiencies in that system you can find
holes in that system you can take
advantage of it i think that's one of
the reasons why they weren't able to
stop the 49ers running game in the
divisional round of the playoffs
the code was cracked by 49ers coach kyle
shanahan and i think with don capers the
idea is to come up maybe with some
different looks some different ways of
doing things some flexibility maybe you
go four three sometimes three four other
times maybe you design a game plan every
week for your defense based upon what
the opposing offense is expected to do
that's the best way to craft the
championship defense a defense that
shifts and morphs and changes
to go along with whatever it's going to
take to stop an offense that you're
going to be playing so look if this
works very good news for the vikings it
shows a level of flexibility from an
older coach who would be justified in
saying i'm going to keep doing what i'm
doing he understands it's not enough to
go to the playoffs every other year the
vikings need to progress farther than
that there's a lot of potential there on
that team and a lot of money has been
spent by the wealths on
players stadium facility
they want to bust through and win a
super bowl and it's not going to be easy
to do it but zimmer is doing everything
seemingly in his power to try to get the
team to that level
ben mcadoo was out of the nfl level of
football for
a couple of years and now he's back in
hey he had a buy out from the giants
don't feel bad for him the guy with the
giant suit and the brill cream hairdo is
now the quarterback's coach of the
jacksonville jaguars a position that
shod khan the owner of the team calls an
embarrassment of riches with the veteran
and former super bowl mvp nick falls and
2019 rookie standout gardner minshew so
ben mcadoo is going to be the guy
responsible for getting the quarterbacks
ready to go working with jay gruden the
new offensive coordinator that gives
doug morone two former nfl head coaches
on the offensive side of the ball and
look they're going to need this team to
perform i think doug marone and dave
caldwell the gm down to their final shot
in jacksonville and they need to make
the most of it i think gardner minchi is
going to be the starter and i think that
means ben mcadoo is going to need to get
through to minshew get the most out of
minshew maybe get minshew to put the
brill cream in his hair wouldn't that be
a look to go along with the mustache but
ben mcadoo beginning the process of
rebuilding his coaching career after a
couple of years out of the game
following that disastrous tenure with
the giants which actually looks better
in hindsight given the way that pat
shurmur flamed out ben mcadoo did more
maybe with less talent than pat shurmur
did in his two years before he was fired
one last point before we wrap this
edition of pftot
there's been talk about the nfl
exploring the possibility of a flex
option for monday night football and
look that's been unheard of when the nfl
introduced the flex for sunday night a
lot of people initially said well we
need to do it for monday night and the
nfl's reaction was you can't do it
logistically it's impossible
you've got teams that that take up whole
hotels you can't just say oh hey uh two
weeks from now you know how we've got
the entire hotel booked for saturday
night change that to sunday night can
you do that for us please that's not
going to be easy to do you have fans who
have arrangements to attend a sunday
game all of a sudden it's a monday game
all of a sudden you're traveling on
different days and you thought you were
traveling and you get maybe two weeks of
notice before you figure it out now if
they're gonna do it they need to give
people more than two weeks but even then
it's going to be a logistical nightmare
and i'm not sure it's something the
league can pull off but my big takeaway
is this
the mere fact that the league is even
considering this
it tells me they've got big plans for
monday night football you know monday
night football stopped being monday
night football when 2006 came around and
nbc
took sunday night football and made it a
broadcast property and monday night
football became a cable property the the
the flex doesn't matter for a cable deal
the cable deal is driven by the money
you earn from being able to say to
people hey buy our our channel we've got
monday night football
when you start thinking about improving
the quality of the late season matchups
via flex option that's when you're
thinking about
putting those games not on cable but on
broadcast because despite all the
changes in the tv business getting games
in prime time on three little networks
is the way to drive the ratings to the
highest possible amount there's still
millions of people that rely on
over-the-air free tv for fox nbc cbs abc
cbs
and
as i said the mere fact the nfl is
considering
the flex option tells me that the play
may be
to have three nights a week when it's
all said and done where there are nfl
games on three letter networks where you
are getting huge ratings thursday sunday
and monday now what that translates to
from a dollars and cents standpoint
remains to be seen maybe there will be
an espn abc simulcast we've seen that
with the pro bowl we've seen that with
the playoff game that espn has had every
year for the past i don't know how many
i can't remember when they picked up a
playoff game it hasn't been all that
long but they picked up a playoff game
and they simulcasted on abc so just keep
that in mind
the monday night football contract ends
after the 2021 season all the other
contracts expire after 2022.
could it be
that monday night football goes back to
broadcast tv and that really would be
something it's every night of the week
that the nfl could have a prime time
game on a big network that's what could
happen thursday sunday monday that means
more money that means higher ratings
bigger audiences more excitement and if
the nfl can pull it off the best
possible games i still don't think they
can pull it off for monday nights but it
looks like they're at least going to
give it a try if not at least give it
some thought that's it for wednesday's
pft ot shireen williams is in for sims
on thursday and friday we'll see you
bright and early on thursday morning for
the next edition of pft
live hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports